it seems like an eternity ago only 89
days ago marks the 26th we broadcast
from the studio a message of hope then
mate the nation was going crazy kovat 19
had exploded we were watching the
numbers every day we're watching the
infection rates we're watching the death
rate it's all over the news it's
consumed the water-cooler talk in
America and pretty soon no one was
standing at the watercooler anymore
businesses were shutting down businesses
were shuttered that and closed some of
them to never reopen schools were closed
concerts were cancelled events were
canceled unemployment numbers were
skyrocketing first 3.6 million the first
week the greatest number we have ever
seen since the Great Depression 3.6
million then 10 million then twenty
million then 30 million and then 40
million in 30 years of running Ramsey
solutions I did something I've never had
to do I sent everyone home to work from
home this place was empty a 200,000
square foot office building and the wind
was whistling through it it was eerie a
handful of us coming in here to do the
radio show and a few essential things
that we had to do to keep the business
running and everyone else is working
from home in 30 years I've never had to
lay a single person off I've never had
to furlough anyone because we've always
been financially conservative and I know
you can imagine that but now I'm
wondering and I'm scared people are
scared all over America they're afraid
of getting sick they're starting to be
afraid that they're gonna lose their job
they're afraid they're gonna lose their
business they're afraid they're gonna
lose their savings they're afraid
they're gonna lose their retirement
they're afraid the world's never gonna
be the same
we were all shook up it was a crazy
crazy time when I walked through here I
felt the same fear that some of you were
feeling I wasn't personally vulnerable
from the economics and no one in my
family was sick thank goodness
a lot of families were experiencing a
different reality when I walked through
here I was worried about the people that
sit right here I was worried about their
kids and their dreams and their lives my
job as the leader is to make sure these
jobs stay in place I'm trying to serve
those families and it put my stomach in
my throat a lot of you were facing fear
of a different kind
for the first time ever maybe you were
facing a foreclosure maybe you had a job
loss maybe you were worried if you were
going to lose all your savings maybe
you're watching the stock market as it
ticked down every day maybe there was
stress in your household
maybe quarantine brought everyone
together and it was lovely and nice but
maybe your marriage was experiencing
some stress maybe that fear and that
worry maybe your little kid looked up at
you and said Boz daddy crying why is
mama crying
I know this story because it's my story
you see when I was 26 years old I built
up a real estate portfolio for million
dollars but I did it dumb way too much
debt and then a calamity hit the economy
shifted and we lost everything we were
sued we were foreclosed on and with a
brand-new baby a toddler and a marriage
hanging on by a thread we were bankrupt
and I remember being that daddy I was
crying
26 years old standing with the shower as
hot as I could barely stand it in my
face crying I didn't know what to do but
I do know this the Sun came out just
like it's coming out now the economy
starting to open up people are coming
out of our caves after our nuclear
winter things are starting to blossom
and bloom spring is here there's the
calm and the promise of the Sun coming
out after the storm after the storms
past and now that the Sun is starting to
come out I had one question in my life
when that happened to me and it's the
same question everyone is asking and
that question is what we're gonna talk
about tonight ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage Dave
Ramsey's
[Applause]
Wow
thank you so the question we're gonna
answer tonight is what now after all
we've been through what now
there once you've heard this story or
three little pigs do you remember the
three little pigs the first little pig
was a short term thinker he was a little
bit immature he said stuff like Yolo you
only live once for you old people you
don't know what that means you only live
once thank God it's Friday oh god it's
Monday we better party while we can and
he built his house out of straw you
remember the story the second little pig
he was kind of ish he listened to the
show but he didn't hear what was said on
the show and so he was kind of ish he
understood we supposed to do but he
didn't really want to put him forth the
effort to do it right and so he built
his house out of what sticks remember
and the third little pick the third
little pig ah this boy he's a long-term
thinker he knows that adults devise a
plan and follow it the children do what
feels good he understands that emotional
maturity demands that we defer pleasure
for a greater good later and he built
his house out of bricks and you know
what happened along came the big bad
wolf and of course little pig number one
made fun of the brick building little
pig you should live your life now buy a
bass boat
get a seadoo on payments get a sister
for your c2 home payments it along came
the big bad wolf and he huffed and he
puffed and he blew his house down
so he went scurrying to his friend that
had built his house out of sticks that
was ish ish sticks this gets worse then
along comes the big bad wolf any huffed
and he puffed and he blew their house
down and they gathered up their stuff
and they ran to their friend's house who
had built it of bricks and Along Came
the big bad wolf and he huffed any
puffed in the house did not fall down we
know the story don't we well guess what
we've all been one of those three little
pigs at different times in our lives
I've been all three of those particular
pigs at different stages of my life in
different areas of my life and everyone
watching across the world right now and
everyone's sitting here with us tonight
is when kovat nineteen hit you were in
the case of one of those three little
pigs
not gonna pick on you if you're the
straw pig cuz I've been the straw Pig
I'm not gonna pick you pick on you if
you're the ish stick Pig because I've
been ish sort of doing things ish
instead of doing them with excellence
and properly and following the
principles then I've been the little pig
in the brick house the timer to and out
of the three I can tell you the bricks
are more fun it's a more fun situation
but some people win kovin nineteen hit
they weren't ready
they had a lot of debt and no money and
when the big bad wolf huffed and he
puffed and he blew their job down they
were in trouble
and some people had kind of been doing a
little bit of this stuff but they really
weren't sold out and so they had a
little bit of money but they still had
some debt because they really hadn't
gotten serious they were ish and they
still felt the tremors and the fear and
even the terror and
was the little pigs there watching
tonight that were in the brick house and
you know what most of them did they felt
real sorry for their neighbors they they
were not told you so people and I'm not
I told you so people because I've been
the other guy I know what it feels like
to have a PhD in D UMB I I've done the
stupid stuff so we're not here to say I
told you so to anybody but I'm so proud
of the little pigs and the brick houses
around the world that I know who from
the strength of their lives were able to
reach out and be generous and help their
friends and help their neighbors and
without an i-told-you-so attitude
instead we're just kind and
compassionate because they remember when
they said Yolo they remember when they
were short-term immature thinkers and
they were in a position to help and they
kind of took great pride in the fact
that they had paid a price to win to be
in a position that when the big bad wolf
huffed and he puffed that their house
didn't fall and of course that's
currently where we are in the Ramsey
family but just a few years back it
feels like we were the other ones and
our house fell yeah so tonight we're
gonna talk about what now what now what
do we do now what's the proper spiritual
outlook on this what's the proper
emotional and financial outlook on this
the economic outlook on this and I can't
cover the medical because all I am is
confused by everyone because they're all
apparently wrong and some of them are
more enthusiastic ignoramuses than other
ones and some of you people that are
really afraid are really angry or really
enthusiastic about your opinion about
their opinion that's wrong so I'm just
totally screwed up on that part I can't
help you with that I've got my opinions
but I'm just like you they're probably
wrong because the information we've all
been making decisions on has been wrong
so we can talk about our lives our
individual lives and the impact in our
decisions of how we're going to move
forward what now
I'll tell you another story and
this is a story from the Bible but even
if you're not a Christian person or a
person of faith don't be offended it's
still a great story
so Jesus and the disciples were walking
along the road and Jesus said to the
disciples who do men say that I am and
some of the disciples said they say that
you're Elijah one of the other prophets
that you're so-and-so and they mentioned
and they name off and Peter speaks up
because Peter if you didn't if you don't
know the Bible Peter was a big mouth
always loud and always his mouth so he's
getting ahead of his tail in and he
speaks up and says you are the Christ
you're the Messiah well it got real
quiet because that's a big bold
statement if you're a Jewish person to
name someone the Messiah is a big bold
statement it got real quiet the
disciples thought oh he's getting ready
get it instead Jesus said well flesh and
blood has not revealed this to you but
my father in heaven and Peter's like God
because see here's the deal you got to
understand and that mindset again this
is a great story if you're a Jewish
person in that century the Messiah was
supposed to come and take and rule over
the entire world and become king of the
world and once Jesus said to Peter I'm
the Messiah Peter's like his right-hand
guy Peters going I'm about to be
vice-president of the world this is good
and they walk along the ways and the
next scene in the story as you continue
to read down the page Jesus begins to
tell them how that he is going to
Jerusalem and he's going to be arrested
by the religious leaders and he's going
to be tried he's gonna be hung on a
cross and killed he's gonna die he's
gonna be in the grave for three days and
he's then he's gonna be resurrected well
this is not Peters plan Peter wants to
be vice president of the world and so
the guy who just a few pages earlier is
saying you're the Messiah when Jesus
starts telling what that means that I'm
not gonna be king of the world as you
understand it but I'm gonna get killed
and raised be raised on the third day
Peter says no do not let it be so
and Jesus turns around can you imagine
of all the people turn around look at
you and saying this he turns around
looks at Peter and says get behind me
Satan would you like to be called Satan
by Jesus this is not a fun trip right
here get behind me Satan because he was
speaking against what was really coming
and of course we know the story
especially those of us that are faith
people of faith we know that Jesus is
crucified he's tried as a criminal
crucified by the religious leaders is
put in the grave in three days later he
is resurrected and he doesn't become
king of the world he becomes king of the
universe
Peter had no idea how good it was gonna
turn out he thought it was this big it
was bigger you see this is what happens
in our lives sometimes things that we
think are going to be one way don't turn
out that way do they say yes they don't
turn out the way they're supposed to
turn out and they sometimes a a marriage
dies sometimes a job or a career track
dies and sometimes a business dies a job
dies sometimes finances die but then
there's a resurrection after a moment in
the dark when it looks for really really
bad on the other side there's a
resurrection and it comes out and it
turns out at the end of the story when
you look back and you go well that's the
best thing that ever happened to me
I was talking to lay though they she
goes you know my starter husband used to
hit me so she called her first husband
and she said I got rid of him because he
didn't understand and I thought my life
had come to an end but this new guy that
I got I'm married
sir galahad he's a gentleman he opens
the door and cares for our family and is
a kind and compassionate daddy what we
thought was gonna be the end of the
world turns out when you look back is
the best thing ever happened to me have
you had that happen to you say yes well
that's what's happening right now you're
living right in the middle of that I
walk through that Sharon and I made a
lot of money and for two kids from two
hillbillies from Tennessee we piled up
about four million dollars worth of debt
and lost everything by the time we were
28 and had the opportunity to start over
I say opportunity as it was dark I was
scared
Rachel Cruise was born that year she was
a little baby the year we filed
bankruptcy we had no idea how this was
going to turn out
I was a baby Christian a brand new
person of faith and I was reading
through the Bible like it was a Boy
Scout manual and I'm trying to find out
what's going on because I don't know how
to get the badges y'all might have done
that it's 4:30 in the morning and I'm
wide awake worried and fretting and I
hit this Scripture and I was just
reading through it and I almost rode
past it but it jumped off the page and
grabbed me her in the neck and shook me
the word came alive those Romans Romans
5:3 through 4 not only that but rejoice
in your suffering now I don't know about
you but I pray different than some of
you rejoice in your suffering my answer
was often so it's not fun a little
whisper in my ear keep reading fool
rejoice in your suffering because
suffering produces perseverance by the
way did you know that there's two major
character qualities of highly successful
people integrity and perseverance
suffering produces perseverance and
perseverance character and I swear God
said on you my boy or a character
and character produces hope there's a
chain of events that happen with the
suffering and I started to understand
that even though I was at the bottom of
the bottom even though I was walking
through the valley and you know what's
in the valley that's where all the
manure is it's fertile for a reason and
I'm walking through the valley
I started understand God's crazy about
me even if I don't own any real estate
even if I'm scared out of my mind that
don't have any answers and then I
flipped over and found the cliche
scripture right from Jeremiah Jeremiah
29:11 the one that's on your wall in
your kitchen maybe it's on all the
little pictures everywhere in the
Christian bookstore right I know the
plans I have for you declares the Lord
plans to prosper you not to harm you
plans to give you a future and hope and
as that started to settle on my spirit
walking out of bankruptcy at the very
bottom at the worst point in my entire
life I started to realize as a
resurrection after the worst point the
Sun comes out there's a resurrection in
other words God is saying you ain't seen
nothing yet you ain't seen nothing yet
people are walking around looking like a
he or is their spirit animal this bad
things are bad there's never gonna be
the same that's right they ain't never
gonna be the same cuz you ain't seen
nothing yet
some of you this is the best thing that
has ever happened to you in your entire
lives and you just aren't far enough
past it yet to understand it we've all
walked those stories we know they're
true we know there's a resurrection we
know that at the end of the story
there's a rebirth
your dreams aren't dead your passions
aren't gone your skills aren't gone your
potential in your future isn't gone
everybody's walking around scared who's
using new normal
after 9 1 1 we did the same thing you
don't ever be the same
the only negative thing that survived
9-1-1 is TSA everything else associated
with 9/11 that was bad is dead
we killed most of it and it needed a
good killing there's you know you listen
you think about the stuff we've been
through in your lifetime the things
you've walked through in your lifetime
oh you touch them is always gonna be
rare I swear y'all just spent way too
much time with Christopher Robin Winnie
the Pooh and your yeah it's scary but
the answer to what now is you say which
little pig was I and the next time
because there will be a next time I'm
sorry it's gonna rain
this blue skies and there's
thunderstorms had a beautiful afternoon
Sunday afternoon Sunday night my dadgum
house got struck by lightning I mean
it's gonna rain it's gonna rain I'm
sorry you say next time I'm gonna be in
the brick house no more ish no more
yellow I'll be in the brick house and
that's for me and my house we will be
able to take care of ours and we will
have surplus to serve and love our
neighbors from we will never again be
here again so the answer to what now is
never again will I be right where I am
unless you're in the brick house your
answer is never again
so we're you're gonna be saying never
again say it again never again moments
happen and they give us a moment when
Sharon and I went through that
bankruptcy we said never again when
people go through a divorce they say
never again when people go through a job
loss in the toxic work environment and
some jerk mistreat them never again come
on put myself in that situation I might
be in another situation but I'm not
doing the same stupid stuff twice
never again sometimes we have individual
never again moments sometimes we have
culture wide never again moments the
Great Depression was a never again
moment for the whole culture they looked
you know people that were affected by
the Great Depression you know
nine-one-one was a never again moment
never again never again are we gonna be
caught unawares
never again 2008 2007 stock market goes
down housing bubble blows up are you
going to be right there next time
there's a problem where are you gonna be
never again never again lots of people
have their lives changed when they
identify there never again moment and
they used that as a point of
transformation we got in touch with a
couple of them and here's what they had
to say I didn't ever think that we were
poor
we didn't have this we didn't have that
nobody had it it was just normal life
and so I would say that I not only
survived the depression but that I
learned from it and it's a positive part
of my life even down
the present
[Music]
we actually opened our first restaurant
in the summer of 2001 on Tuesday
September 11th you know like everybody
we could kind of watched it unfold and
everything changed on Wednesday you know
the divorce was just really that was my
never again moment because we could pray
all day but until we're moving our feet
forward we have to do the work I think
that was another reason with the
marriage you know there was no work
being done it was okay I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it and so once I put into
motion God just said you know what you
got this you can do it the things I did
to get out of debt was just continue to
live below my means but then I picked up
a part-time job and so I was always on
the move constantly doing something
constantly moving it was October of 2007
when they brought the world to a
standstill again or at least in the
United States economy to a standstill we
weren't prepared for it it was in
February of 2009 that I told everybody
that worked for me that we were gonna
have to close that was a really hard day
and I just remember feeling totally
helpless at that point never again
where we're sitting on the plane like
okay we're about to get married so like
now let's go ahead and go through the
finances so I just pulled out my phone
and I just handed it over to to show her
all the the loans all of the loans and I
think that was the moment where I'm not
doing this again
like I'm just I'm just not never get
[Music]
now the depression well I should say the
effect that it had on me even to this
day is that I am very loathe to throw
anything away you save everything yeah
when I was growing up everything was to
be repaired taken care of as we come
into the spring of 2020 I'm now retired
and Lisa is still working we're scared
like everybody else but we're not scared
on the financial side we were fortunate
enough during the pandemic where we did
lose our jobs we were both considered
essential but if we had been negatively
impacted we would have been okay
even when the world is at its most crazy
as it's ever been you know God has
blessed me to be a piece because I took
control of my life
so I'm truly blessed however if I was
not debt-free I don't know where I would
be when this is over
I think that we will recover that people
will maybe not get their same jobs but
they will get jobs we've had recessions
since the Great Depression
but we seem to recover from those I mean
our our economy and our whole social
structure strong enough
[Music]
I'm very optimistic about the
possibility of things getting back on
track
[Music]
my grandpa was a product of the Great
Depression like mr. Chuck there mr.
Chuck sweet he's a guy just like to sit
on that swing with for a little while
probably learn a couple things he lost
my grandpa was a little older than Chuck
and he lost his business and Great
Depression and got a job and he was not
thankful to have that job so thankful
that he kept that job for a same job for
38 years until he retired and I remember
I was 8 years old in 1968 and we were
taking down an old deck in his back yard
and we were pulling the nails how the
boards y'all have done this right and
when I pulled the nail out of the board
like I can't do now it was bent and so I
tossed it in the trash and he said whoa
wait a minute there you go get that out
of that trash they made me put it up and
straighten it out and put in a coffee
can because the Great Depression was his
never again moment and when he passed
away he was a millionaire and he never
made big money but he always saved
because he had a never again moment that
transformed his life as I mentioned a
minute ago Sharon and I had a never
again moment that transformed our lives
sometimes you're never again moment as a
culture wide event like we've all just
been through but recognize it for what
it is sometimes it's an individual event
in your family like Sharon and I went
through but recognize it for what it is
it is not the end it is the beginning of
something new because the Sun comes out
and there's a resurrection and the story
ends better than you thought it was
going to you ain't seen nothing yet
God says you ain't seen nothing yet even
around here at Ramsey we started trying
to figure out a way to survive when all
the revenue crash started crashing all
around us and I got
thousand people work in there and I'm
trying to keep serving people and
helping the people with our stuff
because people desperately needed our
information and also figure out a way to
keep the doors open and keep the payroll
for all those families paid it was an
interesting time to be a business leader
that's an understatement
and so we fast forwarded and changed
product lines stuff that we were going
to launch next year we just launched it
it wasn't completely ready but it was
you know it was get it out there we
weren't planning to do a 14-day free
trial to financial peace but we launched
it out there and a hundred thousand
people got 14 days of free help for
Financial Peace University we weren't
planning to launch the product that
we're gonna tell you about tonight
because it was supposed to be like next
spring we were going to test it and get
it all figured out and yeah it didn't
work out that way and so we're gonna
tell you about something we're really
proud of the night called Ramsey plus
the Ramsey Plus has three components to
it to learn the budget the tracks the
learning is Financial Peace University
and several of the other classes
available to you online and the budget
of course is every dollar and every
dollar sink which allows you to sync up
with your bank and your spouse and
everybody else in track is the budget
the baby steps app which allows you to
track everything and so it's now all
under one heading called Ramsey plus as
of today wasn't supposed to be till next
spring and we're working on Ramsey plus
and Disney comes out Disney Plus people
that look like they think we we copied
them it was on our whiteboard a year
before we heard Disney had a plus
oh well maybe they copied us maybe it
was just a good idea so that's what
Ramsey plus is it's the learning and the
budgeting and the tracking that allows
you to take you're never again moment
and move into the house made of bricks
so the next time you're in a completely
different place so somebody said what
are you guys gonna teach at this whatnow
event what principles are you going to
teach what I've just taught you a few
but the financial principles we didn't
make up any new ones because it turns
out the law of gravity still works
principles that are the truth are the
truth and good times and bad times and
they cause you to win in both sets of
circumstances if something only works in
bad times it's not a good principle if
something only works in good times it's
not a good principle and you know if it
works in good times everybody you know
stupid when things are going really good
stupid can dress up and look smart but
when stuff happens
stupid gets revealed doesn't it Oren
Buffett said when the tide goes out you
can tell who was skinny-dipping so we
are going to go through three or four
principles tonight but they're stuff
you've heard before from us maybe with a
new twist and maybe with this angle of
what now never again never again maybe
there are a little bit more visceral now
maybe they're a little bit more bubbling
inside of your spirit now than they were
maybe now it matters because never again
so to present one of those one of our
Ramsey personalities that I'm
unbelievably proud of as a Remzi
personality but also as my daughter
number one best-selling author two times
over
please welcome to stage Rachael Cruz
thank you thank you guys well I was so
excited about tonight's event as we were
brainstorming what we were going to be
talking about this whole never again
aspect I loved because over the past you
know 90 days I've been talking to people
in all different financial situations
but I've heard over and over again even
if people were doing well to people that
were really struggling these moments of
like I just don't want to feel this way
again what can I do in my life to be
different what can I do with my money to
actually have control and some of those
people were in a lot of pain they lost
her job they were furloughed they were
really really fearful and I know for me
I don't I don't believe that pain is the
only teacher but it is a very thorough
teacher and so when I've had pain and
struggles in different areas of my life
I come out on that other side
intentionally saying okay what what if I
have learned what have I learned whether
it's parenting marriage money like what
are the aspects of this pain what what
have I learned to take with me in the
future to become better in it how can I
learn from this pain and so a lot of
people out there whether you're watching
online or you're here tonight money was
a source of pain and you've had that
never again moment and I think one of
the ways to really control your money
when you say never again am I going to
feel out of control with my money never
again one of the ways to control that is
a budget a budget is one of our
foundational principles we talk about
all the time and I'll tell you
personally even growing up as Dave
Ramsey's kid the budget was the hardest
thing financially for me to do because
I'm a natural spender I'm a free spirits
I loved I loved spending money okay and
so the idea of a budget was like oh my
gosh I can't have any fun it's boring
it's restrictive like no because every
time I heard the word budget it was
always like yeah we can't go shopping
we're on a budget or we're not going on
vacation this year because we're on a
budget yeah we can't go out to eat
tonight we're on a budget my people on
budgets are not fun people
if that is how life is I was like no and
then I had this really weird experience
about five years ago on vacation with my
husband and Winston said before the
vacation as we were getting to the hotel
he said Rachel don't worry about the
budget I'll take care of it because he
likes doing the budget he's you know
he's the nerd like that and so he's like
I'll do the budget because he probably
knows I can keep up with it better than
that then you can Rachel but I'll do the
budget so don't worry just spend some
money do what you need to do and if you
start bumping up against it I'll let you
know and I was like I I'm sorry what
like I can just spend money and he was
like yeah but again like if it's too
much like we'll talk about it and stuff
but I'll just take care of all the
numbers for the vacation I was like this
is my spiritual gift you are letting me
live in my strengths it's a strength of
mine now fast forward about three hours
into this vacation we were like ordering
appetizers at this restaurant I'm like
me can get this is this okay like this
$8 it's a pint we spend this oh gosh I
feel like I need and I realized s as the
free spirit as the spender
I couldn't spend money I couldn't enjoy
it because I was like I don't I don't
know how much we have left in the
category about to eat and our vacation
like oh my gosh and I finally looked and
I was like I have to know what the
budget is he was like what's weird my
wife go and I was like I don't know
she's just gone like that's past Rachel
but it was the moment that I realized in
my life about five years ago that a
budget does not limit your freedom a
budget gives you freedom it gives you
permission to spend money on things that
you want things that you need things
that you value it gives you permission
you can do it you do it without guilt
without shame without question when it's
budgeted and it's plans to spend money
on things you value now the spending
category throughout kovat was really
interesting because as I was doing my
research and talking to people people
really fell into two types of groups
during Kovan there was group number one
that they just saved everything they
they kind of freaked out they just said
you know what I'm gonna just hold
everything back and a lot of Americans
did that sixty-four percent of Americans
said they saved money up to
$7,000 while social distancing because
they didn't take vacation because it was
probably canceled they weren't going out
to eat
they weren't shopping and I was like
yeah you're not shopping because I went
to buy something on Amazon like hair
ties and it was like it'll be there in
three weeks and I was like what it's
like three years I was like oh my gosh
no I won't buy it you know I mean so
maybe like the inconvenience of
everything you just didn't buy whatever
it was but people held held tight and
they saved and some people is out of
necessity because they lost their job
they refer luck they didn't have the
money to spend but some people really
did they pulled way way back and saved
and then group number two I would say
they pulled back for about 30 days I
think a lot of people were like this
there was about 30 days where everyone
kind of held their breath Winston and I
were like this like right when all this
started hitting in March we both kind of
like okay let's just like tap the brakes
on some stuff and let's just see how
this all plays out and and I did I had a
little bit of fear there were a couple
of nights going to bed where I was like
this could get bad like this could be
really bad you know we all had these
questions of who knows what's gonna
happen so you kind of pull back and then
once you kind of settle in the norm if
you were one of the you know people in
America that didn't lose your job and
you were still working you kind of felt
secure again again that was that was
once there myself thankfully we didn't
lose our jobs and we were like okay this
kind of feels steady we kind of see
where it's going and then you start
spending and for me I'm like I open up
my email and I was like every store that
I've ever shopped out in my entire life
since I was five years old is having a
sale and I tell myself and I talk about
it on my show and in audiences all the
time I'm like don't just spin to save
like just cuz there's a sale don't spend
money just to save money and I'm
literally like pottery by JK oh my gosh
and there was like just don't spin
Rachel too safe don't say I'm telling
myself the same principles because I
found myself just wanting to shop and I
wasn't alone according to surveys 54
million Americans said that they spent
more money while social distancing
because there is something about when
you spend money there's a comfort in it
and 43 percent of Americans say that
they they comfort by out of stress out
of boredom and they just sit there and
they're scrolling and they just end up
purchasing
they just buy buy buy buy buy and again
I hate to admit it that I kind of
started to fall into that and I got to a
point where I was like okay this is so
silly
and I would sit there this is so true
it's vulnerable but it's just honest
I would like fill my cart in a store and
then I just delete it and I just say
okay nevermind but I like went through
the process of putting everything in my
car and then I went buy it but what is
that what happens when you spend money
that excitement that you feel or at
least I feel it's like it's dopamine
something chemically is changing in your
body it goes up to the brain the pain
centers in your brain it kind of numbs
out the stress and it feels good but
when you do that on a major level with
money that you don't have and that you
haven't plans for when in some happening
is that short-term feeling it destroys
your long-term goals it destroys the
idea of paper and get out of debt faster
we're gonna pay off the house early
we're gonna save up that emergency about
all the long-term goals you have start
to just erode away because of this
instant gratification feeling and so you
really do you have to make sure what
your spending is plans but again the
spending is so fascinating I found that
before Cova 19 and everything on average
the average American get this would
spend eighteen thousand dollars a year
on non-essential items eighteen grand
why could you what did you just invested
that like it is it is so so wild and
spending things that we don't need again
because we're scrolling and then you're
watching what everyone else is doing you
spend more time on social media while
quarantines you're looking around your
house for probably the first time in a
long time that's how I felt where I was
like okay this is my home like this is
where I live and you're like well I
could replace that couch oh wow are you
you know it looks bad we could mulch it
right you start to see parts of your
life there like I could upgrade this and
again the spending spending spending
spending spending so controlling the
spending whether it's emotional or not
it is so so key and so what you have to
realize is that you will never win with
money you will never win with money if
you do not budget you have got to budget
and be intentional John Maxwell says
that a budget is simply telling your
money where to go instead of wondering
where it went
knowing where it's going and again it
gives you permission to
spend so I find that people don't budget
primarily now for around two reasons one
fear there's there's an anxiety that
Wells up if you've never budgeted before
and you don't have your numbers on paper
you don't know what's going on there is
fear the fear of the unknown and not
knowing but I'll encourage you that a
lot of people think that like my
situation is so bad Rachel if I look at
the numbers I'm it's just gonna reveal
oh it's gonna be terrible terrible
terrible and it might be a little
terrible but it's usually never as bad
as what you think when you get facts on
paper it makes it gives you such a peace
of mind because it's starting to give
you control and then some people don't
budget because they feel like hey we
made it through this we're doing fine we
don't really need it we had some friends
over last week there's some of our best
friends and they've been so smart
financially they were some of the first
friends we met where they were like
saying these goals and stuff that they
want to do with their money I was like
oh wow it's not just us but stupid like
people actually do this that were
friends with and so they're about to pay
off their house in like six months
we're done an incredible job but they're
going on vacation soon they had a rebook
of vacation from one that was cancelled
during all the quarantine stuff and
they're they're talking we're on our
porch and we're just talking about
vacation and and they kind of start you
know kind of arguing a little bit me
nothing big but about okay yeah but that
hotel yeah it was just kind of expensive
we don't wanna go here and let go we
don't you know we could fly but like I
don't know you know this is but all of
it ended up being about how much they're
spending it ended up being about money
so then I finally speak up which I
rarely talk about money with my friends
but I spoke up and I was like well do
you guys know how much you're gonna
spend on the vacation and they kind of
both looked at each other like no not
really and I was like really I was like
that's so interesting cuz if you just
knew the total then you could break it
down and none of this finding would
happen you would know exactly what
you're doing and then my friend like
this was like I know Rachel we haven't
budgeted in like a year and a half and I
was like are you seriously but you're
bout to pay off your house like I know I
feel like we're kind of doing fine like
it's fine
and I just sat not my where I was like
oh wow like they feel like they're fine
and they are they really are they're
about to pay off their house in six
months so even if you're doing fine even
if you're on baby steps four or five six
seven you still
half two budget cuz it still answers
these questions of what are we gonna do
it gives you that boundary gives you
that guardrail
so let's look really quickly at what it
takes to budget number one you want to
do it monthly that's what we always
teach a monthly budget
I took a debt free call with dad up in
the studio last week and the guy doing
is that free scream he said one of the
best things that he learned was how to
budget properly and I asked him so what
were you doing before you you know got
on track with reams of solution stuff
and he said I would budget yearly he was
like and that doesn't work no that
doesn't work like what you can't just
budget for the year and so because every
month is different every month looks
different so do a budget every single
month and then a zero-based budget which
means your income minus all of your
expenses including giving and saving
equals zero so every dollar coming in is
assigned to a category so some of you in
here may know this some of you watching
may but a lot of people don't and for
the first time ever they're really
trying to understand how to control
their money so I'm gonna show you how
easy a budget is so let's just walk
through one just a quick quick example
just so you can see it's fifth-grade
math you can do this we use this will
use a $65,000 income as an example so
it's about four thousand dollars a month
after taxes now we're gonna walk through
recommended percentages really quick and
again recommended so if you have 18 kids
it's probably gonna be a little
different than this if you are single
living in the middle of Iowa it may look
different than this okay so just
recommend it please don't hate me
because some people just hate when I do
but when I do numbers okay we're gonna
start with giving we always recommend
giving very first thing you need to do
when you give something changes in you
there is a joy there's a peace there is
something when you live life like this
and so no matter where you are
financially we always recommend starting
there open that hand and give something
so we recommend 10% so that'll be $400
you want to be saving so we have 10%
there 400 so this is if you're on baby
step one you're saving your $1000 or
baby step three three to six months of
expenses if you are getting out of debts
you will not have that savings line-item
because you're working your debt
snowballing you've had your starter
emergency fund already Morgan's our rent
we
twenty-five percent thousand bucks
utilities five to ten percent $400
transportation gas public transit
whatever it is ten percent four hundred
food ten to fifteen percent six hundred
fun money five to ten percent it's my
favorite two hundred dollars
everyone needs a line item and as
especially if you're married you each
Nino Hein item for this this is very
very important Rachel the line item of
Rachel my budget is my favorite because
you don't have to like be it Target and
be like hey Scarah is that cool you know
no it's mine I've heard a lot about
money that I can spend he has the same
she gets a little bit of breathing room
clothing five to ten percent two hundred
entertainments five to ten percent two
hundred doing much of that and
miscellaneous five percent two hundred
you need a miscellaneous category the
stuff is going to come up that you
forget about mmm Father's Day mm-hmm yep
love you save about 48 hours my sister
was like are we getting a gift I was
like oh oh yeah okay it's Father's Day
isn't it yep that went into the
miscellaneous category for me in our
budgets so having that catch-all is
really really important and so that's it
all of those line items added up equals
four thousand so that's what you do it's
that simple it's that simple to make
living on it is a little bit more
difficult and so one of the parts that
you have to do you have to do is you
have to track your expenses so if you go
grocery shopping if you go out to eat if
you go buy something whatever it is just
go and say okay I'm gonna track it and
put it in that category we have every
dollar the app again the new every
dollar now can it connects to your bank
check it out it's amazing it comes with
Ramsey plus but tracking those expenses
that's gonna help you sound budget
that's gonna be able to tell you how
much you have left in each category and
if something comes up unexpected then
change the budgets that's gonna happen
we had an insurance afford we paid a
certain insurance four times a year it
came up last month we totally forgot
about it
oh and it hit and we were like oh gosh
so we had to go through and adjust
certain categories lower ones to fit it
in change it this is your budget and if
you're married agree on it agree on at
the beginning and if it has to change
throughout the month talk about it
this is your budget okay I want you to
fill the power in that it's not Rachel
Cruz's budget it's not Dave Ramsey's
budget this is your budget make it work
for you and if you have never budgeted
before if you're watching online again
if you've never budgeted before it takes
90 days for your budget to work so give
yourself three months the first month's
gonna be terrible I'm just telling you
it's me awful second ones it's gonna get
a little bit better by the third month
your budget will start working and so
this is a tactical way to get in control
of your money I read a study a few years
ago that talked about how income levels
people are never satisfied with their
income level so they did a study on
people making $50,000 a year and they
said okay what would it take for you to
be satisfied and feel good they said a
hundred thousand dollars they talked to
people making a hundred thousand dollars
a year what would what would you feel
like yeah I'm rich I'm satisfied this is
good
five hundred thousand talked about five
hundred thousand what they say a million
on average talk to someone makes a
million PI two million two million five
minute just it kept going it kept going
the finish line when it comes to money
it seems to always just move if that's
what you're chasing that's ultimately
what you're chasing it moves consumption
is the same way if I could just drive
this car I'll be good you get the car it
could be fun for a little bit but a next
things gonna come up in the next and the
next that finish line keeps moving and
so what I've realized through a lot of
my teaching throughout the last decade
is I talked about that finish line that
you have to be content where you are and
that finish line always moves but for
tonight I've realized the starting line
keeps moving a lot of people don't want
to start they say okay well I'm gonna
wait till everything's better like
everything's better just take the
weather app right before I got out here
and there's a dust storm coming up
through the Gulf of Mexico right now I
was like what it's happening like the
cicadas should just come out this summer
I mean like it's just it's crazy I'm
like no something is always going to
happen if you wait till everything is
perfect and satisfied then you're gonna
be waiting a long time so start and at
some event small ways like fine to you
know find a night on the calendar this
week to do your budget no no no
tonight do it tonight because the
starting line is gonna keep freaking
moving do it tonight because I'm telling
you when you first do it and you get it
the control that you finally will have
over your money it's gonna you're gonna
have so much peace so much peace because
you're the one telling your money what
to do versus your money telling you what
to do so doing the budgets important and
then also the emergency funds so the
next man coming up to talk about that as
play one of my favorite people on the
planet he has the best voice in the
world so prepare your hearts but please
welcome up number one best selling off
their incredible teacher Chris Hogan
[Applause]
well hello how are you good good listen
this kovat situation has taught me a few
things
how many of you have crazy neighbors
okay I have a neighbor that cuts his
grass at 5:00 a.m. yeah yeah I went out
and I gave him the look like this which
meant stop he didn't stop so you know
what I did I took his lawnmower yeah
I took it I did I went and pushed him
down and it took his lawn more I didn't
do that I'm just playing but I thought
about it okay I really did this kovat
thing has awakened us and helped us to
see things a little bit different I've
been spending a lot of time with my boys
and the reality is is we've been doing a
lot of stuff so we've been playing in
their games fortnight you all know about
that call of duty okay turns out we
played so much call of duty I started
having dreams show them the photo okay
this is when you know you're playing too
much okay plus I've got an arthritic
thumb now all of a sudden from trying to
keep up with these young kids and who
knew that toilet paper ends hand
sanitizer would become an item right and
you become really aware like my boys I
would hear them in the bathroom and it
sounded like they were playing will of
fortune with the toilet paper in there
you know I'm like boy troop seats -
that's all you get and they're pumping
sand hand sanitizer like it's chocolate
syrup you know I'm like slow down we
awaken to some things and it caused some
dreams you all have had some weird
dreams you've been frustrated and
irritated and too much I think we can
dream so much that we forget that we're
in control and what we have to do is
take back control in the midst of this
unknown and the mists of this
frustration and irritation we can't
forget that we're in control a wake-up
call for me was years ago I released my
first book in 2016 retire inspired and I
was in Denver at a book signing and a
lady stood in line with her 12 year old
son
and she was african-american lady
twelve-year-old son waited for 20
minutes to get up to me and she had my
book and I said ma'am can I sign your
book she goes nope I said do you want to
take a picture nope I said well honey
what can I do for you right and she
looked at me with her twelve-year-old
hand saw his hand in her hand she looked
at me and said this the cycle ends here
and she walked off it took me a few
minutes to understand the magnitude of
what had just happened do you know what
she was saying the cycle and her family
of not handling money well ends here the
cycle of her not being in control ends
here the tears won't welled up in my
eyes and I can remember mama Hogan doing
something similar for me and my brother
the cycle ends here I'll never forget
that day I'll never forget the look in
her eyes because she meant that I wish I
would have gotten her name and her
number to keep up with her but I assure
you the cycle ended that day because she
made a decision about what she was going
to be in control of and for a lot of you
you've been thinking that a little bit
but maybe you haven't said it maybe you
haven't said never again you've had that
thought that I don't like being where I
am or I wish things would get better or
just can I just do a little bit if this
was just in no no no that's your never
again moment I want you to stamp it I
want you to own it because something in
you will change when you look at that
and you'll think totally different I
know for me I've been there
battered and bruised but I've said never
again will I not be prepared never again
will I be worried about somebody else's
opinion never again when I not rely on
my Lord and Savior to get me where he
wants me to go and you have to have the
courage to verbalize that and I want you
to own it I want you to think
differently and stop worrying about
people's opinions of
ian's are like yesterday's everybody's
got them you get to decide for you and
when you make that decision like that
single mom did that day something
changes in your spirit and you have to
keep deciding not just today but every
day that you wake up and when you do
that things change we've all been
knocked down this kovat situation has
caused all kinds of financial drama
think back to February we had the lowest
unemployment we've ever had the
economy's boom and the stock market's
rocketing who would have thought in 30
days it would all go away nobody would
have ever dreamed that but here's what I
know for sure I've done almost 200 media
hits in the last three months you all
and I'll keep telling people what you do
going forward will define the rest of
your financial future what's you do
going forward what do you believe is
possible for you and I don't care what
you come from what I'm worried about is
what are you going to what are you
believing is possible for you and I
truly want people to really wake up into
this moment it has to become visceral
don't tiptoe around this what I've
learned about life is if you don't learn
a lesson you get to repeat that bad boy
and so let's learn let's make decisions
for ourselves we've seen this in history
y'all have just forgotten raise your
hand if you remember y2k there's some
young people in there bless your hearts
okay that was back in 1999 people lost
their minds because the calendar was
changed into 2000 and people were
hoarding candles and ramen noodles
I had a jar of peanut butter the size of
that table oh you had to open it with
two hands maybe that was a big jar Geist
I ain't messing with you
[Music]
December 31st 1999 came the calendar
changed what happened say nothing lo and
behold 9/11 comes attacked by cowards
many innocent people lost their lives
and we were scared we know what was
going to happen
stock market collapsed guess what it
came back
same thing with y2k same thing in o2 and
o3 with SARS that other epidemic that
scared us market went down it came back
so same thing in the recession of Oh 709
market went down it came back do you
hear a trend say yes don't forget the
trend and don't forget history because
if we forget we get to repeat and so our
mind has to change and so I want you to
understand some of you found out that
you didn't quite have the safety net you
wanted to have the emergency fund Dave's
been talking about that thing for 30
years three to six-month emergency fund
work with me here kovetz been going on
about how long three months hello
three to six-month emergency fund man's
been saying it I've been saying it
Rachel's been saying that 3 to 6 3 to 6
and lo and behold we've been in a 3 to 6
months type situation and if you had it
your solid if you didn't you know you
need it and if you're in the middle and
you weren't sure now you know without a
shadow of a doubt that it's necessary
but you've got to have a mindset that
you're gonna get this in place rachel
says don't let your emergency fund just
be for emergency fund we know nowadays
we don't have to go to malls we don't
have to go to shopping plazas we can hit
one button and 17 boxes will show up if
you can do stupid in your home and
nobody else knows we've all been there
so it takes self-control we got to have
goals bigger than our wants I tell
people you have to be grown-up enough to
tell a won't it needs to wait and it
doesn't mean you can't have some stuff
but it just don't stuff to have you and
we have to shift their mindset I'm gonna
tell him myself
you've got to begin to look at your
budget to identify where are you
overspending 16 years ago I decided to
get serious about money and I realized
you know where my money was going the
grocery store I was spending 400 a week
don't judge me
she went I will tase you I'm just
playing but 400 a week what was I doing
I wasn't shopping out in need I was
shopping out of habit and I'm telling
you that so you can wake up and start to
look and go wait a minute
I need to get an emergency fund I need
to plug my money leaks I don't want to
keep doing the same thing over and over
and so as we've been saying a 36 month
emergency fund excuse me a 3 to 6 month
emergency fund is exactly what you need
to have so how do you get one of those
you get intentional with your budgeting
you sell some stuff you start to get
really intentional and you take on a
second job if you have to but get that
cushion between you and life and make
sure that not only when you have that
cushion you keep it hear me if you ever
end up using the emergency fund job one
is to replenish it so you want to keep
that in a money market account keep it
liquid so you can get to it but if you
ever use it job one is to replenish it
always keep it there
nobody knows what's coming here in the
next several months I do know without a
shadow of a doubt I don't know the
future but I know who holds it can I get
a name in but what I want to do is do my
part for me and I want you to do your
part for you and your financial future
as well so how do you do it well you get
this three to six month in place
immediately that's what you have to have
now you can save money and not only
track it inside of Ramsey plus they've
just told you about it where it gives us
a chance to stay connected you all doing
the media heads I'm talking to people
with my show the Chris Hogan show people
are not connected to the money they
don't know they're working hard to make
it but they're not making it work hard
for them so I want to encourage you to
be plugged in and know what's going on
sell some stuff
I had three sets of golf clubs when I
got serious about getting out of debt
and I'm a horrible golfer okay no I look
good walking into the tea box you think
this boy is good then I swing and you go
this boy's parable right cuz the ball
goes 300 yards I just don't know where
it went
right be intentional give up some stuff
and gotta be smart okay you have to have
that never again moment with this
emergency fund and when it comes to
talking about retirement listen to me
I told you the times in history don't
cash out your retirement do not we told
people this and y2k told people this and
for SARS told people this in the great
recession and the market came back lo
and behold right now the market is
coming back the cares Act allows people
to access their 401k I wanted to go to
Washington and just shake all of them
and say don't tell people that don't
steal from your future to clean up your
present because now what you're gonna
have to do is pay income taxes over the
next two years for what you pulled out
and it stops growth 42% of Americans
believe they'll never retire 56% of
Americans say they lose sleep thinking
about retirement hear me be intentional
with your investing okay be intentional
now some people have lost their jobs
they didn't have income and if you don't
have income you can't invest right now
so you've got to get your stable your
income stabilized again but if your job
is okay and your income is coming back
if we don't invest my friends we're not
gonna get to spend later the
government's not gonna save the day you
and I know the government can't count
they can't so why on earth would you
count on them for your financial future
so we've got to wake up and look at this
we got to get our own cape we have to
invest for several reasons inflation you
all can remember gas prices five years
ago versus where they are now well think
about five years from now what's that
going to look like even more expensive
so we got to grow money and investing
allows us to do that but I want you to
understand what you're investing in I
want you to sit down with an investment
professional look at your portfolio look
at that 401k
about it a lot of people think if you go
see an investment professional they're
gonna judge you that's not true people
think it's like going to the principal's
office right I remember back I was in
fifth grade they came over the
loudspeaker the principal said this
Christopher Hogan please come to the
office what did all my classmates do
whoo
and I gonna lie to y'all I was a long
wall because I was trying to think back
to all the things I had done I get up
there I turned the corner mama Hogan is
standing there talking to the principal
and she's smiling it was like happy
before death or something I don't I
don't know what it was she's grinning
from ear to ear and I get up close to it
thinking well let's just accept death
and she goes hey baby you forgot your
lunch money the release and my little
chicken heart do you know how happy I
was
it was the longest walk going back to
the homeroom do you know how I walked
back after that I had a little skit
right and I can walked in and they all
were looking at me like is he alive I
was like lunch money people sense of
relief some of you are fearful of going
to sit down and talk to an investment
professional you think you're gonna get
judgment you're not you're gonna get
help you're gonna get guidance you're
gonna get gained confidence in what
you're doing and where you're going so I
want you to get connected with that a
lot of people tell me Chris I'm I'm
worried with investing I understand but
don't go it alone you need to know what
you're invested in you need to know your
risk tolerance you need to know what the
plan is and your timeframe an investment
professional will help you do that I get
a lot of people refuting me on my show
then go but but Hogan you don't
understand you know like they're getting
a company match and they go Hogan you're
understand I don't want to stop
investing to get out of debt yeah you do
because if you don't have an emergency
fund you're exposed you're exposed your
OneCard problem away or a job layoff
away from being destitute so no I don't
care about the match if you have debt or
Hogan you don't understand the market
it's on sale right now if I get in now I
can grow money
I understand but if you don't have an
emergency fund you're exposed and it's
not going to do you any good
so I want you to be wise with this be
very very intentional I want you to hear
me never again have that statement have
that thing inside your heart never again
will you not have a plan and never again
will you allow yourself to feel that
feeling see some of you think you see me
up here with this nice clothes on and
you think Hogan you've been doing this
money stuff a long time you must be fine
I am but I don't forget the times of
laying in bed worried being concerned
having your Joy's taken away from me
from some financial decisions you've
made thinking it'll never get better I
do remember that I remember the fear and
the crazy thing is we'll try to smile to
act like everything's okay and the eyes
will tell you the story of a marriage
hanging on by a thread
cuz you're tired of that money fight or
kids don't understand why mommy and
daddy aren't happy anymore well they
won't play what this like they used to
because mommy and daddy are scared cuz
collectors keep calling because the car
broke down and you don't know how you're
gonna get it fixed but you try to get up
to play like everything's okay no I
ain't forgot as a matter of fact that's
what gets me about a bit to talk to
people every day on the radio
cuz I think that far away from it I can
go back and grab it and I can look at it
or the faces of people that have looked
at me and they said they didn't think it
was gonna be okay or the guy that came
into financial coach with me 14 years
ago said he felt like suicide was the
answer and I put the pen and paper down
and I grabbed his hands and I prayed
with it
I said your family needs you this is
just funny don't quit on them they need
you you can fix this you start to
realize the magnitude of this stuff the
grip it will have on you
husbands talk to your wives about your
fear this society wants you to man up
and act like
everything's okay fear is real and so
are you wives talk to your husbands
about your fear I want you to team up
and hear each other
but then help each other support and
encourage and if you're single or newly
single find somebody that loves you
enough to listen and then talk but talk
won't cure this we got to have a plan
and we got to have some intensity and I
hope many of you will make this night
the night that if you're okay then
you're gonna go faster and if you're not
okay you're gonna do better and if
you've been wishy-washy playing around
with it thinking you're going to get
serious one day make this the day
because we don't know what else is
coming you can do it and we're here to
help this the scripture day talked about
Jeremiah 29:11 Bor that means something
you can see it those words mean
something to me
because I realized not only did he have
plans for me but I need to have a plan
for him to put him first in my life and
to follow him too intently and spend
times I thought Lord where did you go
and his hand has been right there it
turned out I'm the one that let go not
him so be intentional moving forward be
intentional and understand you need to
connect in community this money stuff is
not something you go at alone you need
people around you
Ramzi plus has that community talk with
people and most of all if you're married
talk to each other and hear each other
but team up with each other come up with
those goals for the sake of your family
one of the things that motivates me with
my three boys is that one day when I'm a
granddaddy I want to be the kind of
grandparent that I grew up with they
didn't have a lot of money but we had a
lot of time and front porches and back
porches means something to me
because that's where we spent time
hanging out our granddad had given me
big red gum at age four it felt like a
charcoal briquette and my mouth
I'm moving it around so I my tongue is
burning all over he goes boy are you
okay yes sir watch that he won't let him
down or my grandmother grabbing my hand
saying baby I believe in you and I'm so
grateful for those deposits because I
haven't forgotten them and I've lost all
of my grandparents now I don't have them
anymore but I haven't forgotten the
deposits don't you forget your deposits
either see when you get tired you need
to think back to the family that went in
front of you the people that spent time
depositing stuff in you they didn't do
that for no reason they did that because
you are worthy now what I want you to do
is get your courage back dust yourself
off remember the Lord and Savior that's
brought you to where you are and
remember where you're going because of
the people that have gone before you
don't waste those lessons deposit them
into your kids deposit them into your
grandkids and think differently the
crazy thing is is nobody can control
what we tell ourselves and if your mind
and telling you some evil nasty stuff
mute it and change the track tell your
stuff some positive encouraging things
cuz you're gonna need it
this journey is not easy but you can do
this and we're here to help make this
year never again moment make this the
time that you're making this stand for
something this kovat 19 is going to go
down in history what you do next will
determine your financial history what
are you gonna do are you gonna lay down
or are you gonna sit down or are you
gonna get up and chase your dreams I
believe in you I believe in you I know
you can do this and we're here to help
god bless you all thank you for your
time
help me welcome back to the stage mr.
Dave Ramsey
[Applause]
I could listen to him read the phonebook
[Applause]
so we say never again and then we learn
the principles that cause that to be a
truth is just saying it enough changing
and doing different things so you get a
different outcome is what matters
Rachel says get on a plan a written plan
do you know nobody wins the Super Bowl
by accident was a plan after the Super
Bowl is over the little reporter doesn't
run out on the field and say so so how
did you win the Super Bowl and the guy
goes oh no I just got off the bus and
there was never says that but executing
a plan in various areas of his life his
entire life since he was seven years old
to get to play in that game much less
win that game you do not win as an
accidental act winning is not random
winning is a series of decisions that
cause you to be standing there accepting
the trophy and that's true with money
and so your series of decisions is
called a budget and then you put the
emergency fund in place because it's
gonna rain because we already talked
about the Three Little Pigs and when
stuff happens when we have events in our
lives or events in the culture like a
kovat and we say if I've got the
emergency fund in no debt because I was
on a plan and then I don't take my
investments out and these are the four
principles and so we need to remind you
that the borrower is slave to the lender
the rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is slave to the lender I'm
known for a lot of things and I'm hated
for a lot of
but I'm really known for having gotten
millions and millions of people to
believe that they could take the steps
to get out of debt and then they went
and got out of debt millions millions
and so to the extent that you want to
stay in debt you're what's known as
wrong it's a dumb idea because you know
what happens when you don't have any
payments your money you know what
happens when you don't have any payments
and garbage like this hits you don't
have a problem you don't have an issue
you're free and the way people decide to
change their lives after an event like
we've just gone through is they say I've
had it
let's brown the great motivator says
people change the direction and the
trajectory of their lives when they
finally have an I've had it moment a
never again moment no like that woman
walking up in building Chris Hogan's
book line no it stops here it ends here
and until you believe that down inside
of you you can have all the intellectual
discussions and theoretical flowcharts
you want to have and nothing's gonna
happen you got to do it and you're not
gonna do it until it boils up inside of
you growing up over here on the other
side of the tracks in Antioch Tennessee
and the suburbs
I was a little hillbilly kid with a bird
haircut they had to cut the hair off for
it to be bird back then all these little
neighborhood kids 100 degrees and August
air conditioning in the 1960s was fairly
new still it was called a luxury we're
running in and out of the house running
in and out of the house running in out
of the house and our parents all had
these sayings you know like he raised in
the barn
leaving the door open I never knew I
didn't know what it meant to be raising
the barn but apparently people who are
raising the barn leave the doors open I
don't know so but we're running in and
out running in and out and my mama's
temperature is just coming up as the
temperature is coming up in the house
right and finally towards the end of day
she would say that's it I've had it the
worm has turned
what
we had no idea what that man other than
the beatings were getting ready to begin
right I mean it was found out later with
Shakespeare who knew mom knew
Shakespeare but no arm this turn you got
to have that moment don't you I've had
it no more
now if you've had a never again moment
or you create one out of this cultural
moment that's what's going to happen
inside of you it's gonna boil up and
you're gonna say because see when you
say I've had it like that you no longer
give a rip what anybody else thinks
people who have had it people who say
never again other people's opinions
don't even show up I actually should
care more what y'all think but I don't I
love y'all I want to help you but some
of you people on Twitter are cuckoo
Zoids
and you send me these letters and say
these things you're just nuts so I
certainly don't care what you think I
love you I appreciate you I'm glad
you're with us on you know our live
stream I'm glad you braved and came in
here tonight and hung out with us in the
studio audience I appreciate all that
and I want to help you I want to give
you the tools to win in your life but
the truth is one of the benefits of
having gone broke and I've had an I've
had it moment is I don't structure my
life and make my decisions based on
taking a poll because all those people
aren't on be there when I'm 72 they
ain't gonna be there when I'm broke in
return all those people aren't gonna be
there when I'm sitting and looking at my
grandbabies they're the only ones that
matter so I'm not taking a poll the law
of gravity is real you jump off a
building you hit the sidewalk the
borrower is slave to the lender
you know how you'll know when that's
true when you don't have any payments
anymore and you say I'm free it changes
everything
and they come on the radio showing they
scream fifty to sixty million dollars a
year paid off live on the air all the
others didn't get on hundreds of
millions of dollars a year people
screaming that's someone who said I've
had it never again
I'm done not living like this anymore
I'm never gonna be without an emergency
fund I'm not gonna live without a plan
because I'm not free when I'm living
without a plan I'm just wandering along
like a dad-blame four-year-old and then
wonder why I'm broke there's you've got
no plan all the money comes in and
they're just gonna see like you're in
Congress I'm not living like that
anymore Pat it so how you get out of
that well there's four or five things
you gotta do the first thing you do is
you stop borrowing money that was
insightful if you want to get out of
debt don't borrow any more that's the
first step get your scissors out light a
little candle have a plastic-surgery
party applies ectomy chase this American
distress discover freedom what's in your
wallet money
you're weird Dave target you're weird
you're right I am weird normal people
don't live successful lives
they have mediocre lives or mediocre in
the way they take care of themselves
they're mediocre and their relationships
their children are mediocre their
careers are mediocre and the way they
handle their money is mediocre because
they don't pay attention and they're not
intentional and I want you to win I want
you to win like you've never won before
but it requires that you're different
because there's a reason we call people
average there's a reason we say things
are average you don't want to be on that
list you want to be in a different place
so the first thing stop borrowing more
money the second thing is save some
money start your emergency fund we call
baby step one $1,000 and baby step three
is three
six months of expenses save some money
save some money you know there's a
proven mathematical fact wealthy people
save money that's how they got money
this is deep isn't it
y'all struggling to keep up okay that's
how it works right next one is take a
part-time job take an extra job take
some overtime my grandmother used to say
is a great place to go when you're broke
to work go down to Home Depot get you a
leaf blower rich people are afraid of
leaves make you some money get crazy
with this bust into it sell stuff sell
something so so much stuff the kids
think they're next and the dog eBay and
put the cat on Craigslist I love my
babies don't worry about that
I mean seriously we got to think we have
enough junk in our lives to start the
plan start working when you say I've had
it I had a young man on the radio today
is incredible young man it works the
railroad and he was listening to me
there's a neat story hit all the toys
you could get and a seadoo and a
motorcycle a big truck and single guy
and he just had just stuff and he just
started naming off all the toys and he
said he had that I've had at moment he
had that never again moment and he said
this is not taking me where I need to be
for my daughter
and he rose up in nobility and he sold
the sea-doo to finish paying the
motorcycle off and then he started
looking the motor second he goes that's
not taking me where I want to go so he
sold it and you watched him mature right
in front of you not that you can't have
a motorcycle or a CD you can you just
shouldn't be in a position that they
have you you should have them they
should just be a toy in the toy box and
you know they're not a toy when you got
payments on the last thing last step out
of debt is prayer really works your
heavenly Father is crazy about you and
he owns the cattle on a Thousand Hills
he owns the hills your dad is crazy
about you
and he's really rich falling home et
prayer really works I can't pray God's
mad at me you don't know about all the
dadgum bad things I've done Dave listen
he's not mad at you
sometimes he and the Angels sit around a
laugh at you or sometimes they just
shake their head and go I mean think
about it
how many y'all got enough kids that you
got a stupid one don't raise your hand
if you're sitting by them okay think
about your Heavenly Father he's got a
few stupid kids don't he I've been one
of him I know he's not mad at you he
just misses you need to check in you
check in because we even love our stupid
ones don't we all that's just him yeah
and we really love it when the stupid
ones say never again and start changing
don't we that's the most reward you can
have as a parent or a grandparent as
watch one of them turned their little
lives around your heavenly father's no
different prayer really works so we're
gonna get on the budget we're gonna have
an emergency fund we're gonna invest and
learn about investing as we do it we're
gonna leave the investments in place and
we're not gonna panic and jump off the
roller coaster in the middle of the ride
because no one gets hurt on a
rollercoaster ride except those that
jump off in the middle
we're gonna keep investing steadily
steadily steadily steadily all the data
we have on studying ten thousand
millionaires say they became
millionaires by getting their homes paid
off staying completely debt-free of
consumer debt and investing steadily the
number three occupation among the
millionaires in Chris Hogan's study for
his book every day millionaires the that
became millionaires starting from
nothing as teachers and one doctors net1
lawyers and in fact doctors weren't even
in the top five it wasn't about how much
they made it's how they handled what
they
had steadily investing steadily
investing and staying out of debt so
that they could instead of having a five
hundred and fifty dollar car payment on
a kid hauler we've lost our minds well I
wanted him to be safe you're talking to
a generation used to fall asleep in the
back window okay
the only airbags we had was if my
grandmother rode with us I mean come on
I mean really bless her soul we loved
her we've lost her mind Joe it's time to
just have some principles and say this
is how the law gravity works I'm gonna
keep an emergency fund I'm gonna stay on
a plan I'm gonna get out of debt and
stay out of debt I'm gonna invest and
continue to invest and then you're gonna
see things change
it really isn't rocket science but it's
about having that moment and we've had a
cultural opportunity to say what now
never again
so now we're gonna say say it with me
one more time so earlier tonight I told
you a little bit about Ramsey plus I
want to make sure you guys understand
we're gonna give you a free trial to
Ramsey plus we want you to jump in there
we want you to enjoy this and I want you
to figure this out with us we're
launching this thing and it feels we're
kind of like just jumping you know
because we wanted to test it and be all
smooth Sally right but no we're doing it
okay
so that's part of what's happening here
and we're kind of so were you this is
like like the baby's being born tonight
and we don't even know about babies
doing it you know so this is it so the
learned side of Ramsey plus of course is
the cornerstone of it is Financial Peace
University the nine lessons are in there
in the free trial get the free trial and
watch it okay the nine lessons are there
we also put the legacy journey lessons
in there which is the follow-up class to
Financial Peace University you can learn
what to do after you win with money you
change your legacy you change your
family tree we put the smart money smart
kids lessons in there
merely rachels the teacher on that I'm
in it as well and this is for you
parents of children so you can show you
you can learn to teach you can learn how
to teach your children how to handle
money so when they're older they won't
be in your basement because any Eagle
that doesn't leave the nest soon enough
becomes known as a turkey and then from
there we've thrown in some other lessons
that we put in there Rachel has done a
whole thing on budgeting budgeting that
actually works it's a quick little
lesson and it goes deeper into budgeting
than she did the night it would be a
little bit of what you saw tonight again
but because that's how it works and it's
her walking you through every dollar and
exactly how to use it how fill it out
and how to get it going and a jump start
lesson to get you going because
sometimes when you get started unity you
need to go right and that's Hogan and
Rachel doing that together so it's all
kinds of content in this and it's all in
there and it's all in the free trial and
you're gonna learn and we're going to
keep putting more content in two of
those lessons were added in the last 45
days okay
the less the budgeting lesson the
JumpStart lesson added recently and
we're updating and changing Financial
Peace University lessons all the time
and constantly iterating because we're
delivering it to you digitally so we can
change it all the time now we don't have
to throw away a whole truckload of CDs
or DVDs every time we change a stupid
thing anymore so it's a wonderful
environment to be in right and so once
you're learning then you got a track you
got to the budgeting you do the
budgeting and that's every dollar sink
because it syncs up you and your spouse
if you're married both have it on your
phones you can tell what each other's
doing you can talk to each other hey my
Costco I'm gonna do this I need to buy
this okay cool or whatever you can be
watching your budget you know exactly
what's going on whether it syncs with
your bank and it syncs with the baby
step tracker so she showed you Rachel
showed you how to lay out the budget on
that takes about ten minutes to lay it
out and it's free in the free trial so
get in there and set it all up and play
with it and learn how to do this stuff
it stretches your brain and once you
stretch your brain it will never return
to the same shape it was before that's
how this works and then we're gonna let
you track and this is a brand new app
that is not available anywhere in any
App Store has never been out there it's
the baby steps tracker because what
we're finding is this y'all are putting
stuff like little thermometers on your
refrigerator as you're getting out of
that or little chain links of
construction paper all over the freaking
house and it's $1,000
and we're getting them off and on all
you're doing is tracking your progress
you want to see and feel your progress
which is good that's very wise so we're
trying to help you do that in this app
we're gonna walk you through the baby
steps and help you track and let you
feel your progress because if you don't
feel progress you won't keep going and
we want to help you we're good at this
y'all that's all we do I mean we're the
best in the world at this stuff right
here and our team you could tell by
looking at this stuff these guys man I
went in one of the meetings with these
tech guys the other day and I'm own the
company and I didn't know what they were
saying I had to stop and go okay quit
using all these acronyms y'all sound
like you're in the military everything's
got initials so you tell me what the
flip y'all are talking about in here not
because I'm scared of you but I just
kind of curious because it's a sounded
like a foreign language it's a
completely different vernacular but
they're brilliant and the stuff they're
pulling together man we've got these
these digital ninjas all over this place
that are just they're just killing it
man it's unbelievable I'm so proud of
them and when you get in this you're
gonna see how robust it is that's one of
the terms they use if it's good it's
called robust okay and so I didn't I
thought I thought Hogan was robust but
no this is this is this is robust so so
it's everything you need to take control
of your money it's learn budget and
track and all of that has tremendous
depth to it and you're gonna love it get
in there and try it it's completely free
if you're ready to say never again I'm
not gonna let paycheck-to-paycheck again
never again never again am I gonna be
caught flat-footed when the storms come
like they're a surprise not a surprise I
mean Colvin is a surprise I can't even
spell Kovan six months ago but we know
stuff is gonna happen I saw it on a
bumper sticker stuff is gonna happen
right you say never again am I gonna
live out of control never again am I
gonna sacrifice my money health for my
short-term immature impulses I'm gonna
enjoy my life
have some depth some richness to it
feeling like a real adult when I get to
do things that are fun but also get to
be someone that I like looking at in the
mirror because it's changed how I
function and who I are who I am somebody
that who are too that's that's from the
Pope the cartoon Pogo okay um tonight
you can get started for free all you got
to do is go if you want the free trial
to mc+ just go to Dave Ramsey comm slash
and ever again everybody saying never
again
Dave Ramsey comm slash never again it's
completely free this event tonight was
completely free are you seeing a trend
here with this digital stuff pretty easy
to do fairly inexpensively for y'all so
it's it's fun and we get to be who we
are around here which is teachers and
motivators and
we get to show you how you can see the
sunlight again that there's a
resurrection and there's life after this
and it's gonna be better it's gonna be
better it's not gonna be worse now for
the first thousand of you around the
world or in this room wherever you are
the sign up for it chris hogan and i
sign up for the at dave ramsey calm
selection ever again for your free trial
or MC plus the first thousand they did
that starting right now go we're gonna
do a free webinar chris hogan are going
to answer questions live for the first
thousand from 11:00 a.m. Central time
next Tuesday until noon next Tuesday so
we're gonna be on there with you for an
hour just he and I answering questions
I'll let him answer most of them because
he's smarter than I am but I'll let him
think so but anyway so if you want if
you want to be part of that it's a free
trial we're not gonna steal anything
from you
we've never stole anything from you
we've always figured out that if we help
enough people we don't have to worry
about money no you know the trial will
end and some of you will join and give
us money and that's a good thing too
we're not ashamed of that it's not a
bait-and-switch
it's a free trial when once you get in
there and enjoy the hard work of the
people around this building that have
built things with you in mind and they
want to serve you and they want you to
take this to another level and they want
to take this moment in time
and change everything so when I had my
never again moment it changed my life I
wouldn't be Dave Ramsey I'd be a guy
that owned some real estate named Dave
Ramsey guys I got to tell you the sun's
coming out
but capture capture the moment and it's
not for your harm capture the moment and
say yeah I hear I stubbed my toe I hurt
that that that felt bad I don't like
that but I'm gonna say never again so
say it with me one more time 1 2 3 never
again am I gonna be in that situation
never again as American Express gonna
call my house unless it's a wrong number
never again never again I'm not gonna
wonder if a wrecker pulling up in my
driveway is there to pick up my car as a
repo there must be a repair needed
because there's no payments I got called
me up the other day he goes David's
going around the newsroom and our local
channel down here that your Viper got
repo'd that's very cool and he goes what
do you mean cool
I said no I had a Viper and you stupid
butt guy if I'd have had one that sure
wouldn't had a car payment on it Dave
Ramsey have a carpenter you don't think
that wouldn't go on the front page of
some left-wing rag of course it would
you got to be kidding me
so you gotta say never again and once I
did that I drew that line in the sand it
changed the trajectory of my life and
that's what I want for you because we
love you
we want good things for you all of us
have messed up just learn from it
whichever little pig you is learn from
it learn from it
god bless y'all thanks for coming
tonight
like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]